without showing the parasite you must
find one person on the street in new
york who's willing to trade the shoot
off their feet for this mystery pier
let's go so i go grab my box right there
we go
bro i like them air jordan six those are
hair sixes that came out what size is
those
ten and a half i got a size 11 in this
box right here mystery shoe i don't know
what it is you all know what it is
trading for me right now i like your
shoes man what's out with those uh 11
11. hey i got a pair of shoes right here
inside the leatherman are you willing to
trade those shoes off your feet right
now for these size 11. well the shoes on
your feet for the shoe in this box
whatever it is
brand new those like a 7 out of ten
let's do it uh okay yeah you gotta do it
you gotta do it all right let's get it
let's get it he's yours look at that bro
look at that bro look at that bro and
yours yeah there we go still deal yes
sir those are fire by the way those are
the jordan ones no problem